à la Réunion ils sont chez eux Gaëtan
Roussel Arnaud Samuel et Robin Félix les
piliers de Louis attaque rêvaient
devenir dans l'île depuis plus de 25 ans
et ses choses faites après les nuits
parisiennes le groupe mythique de rock
français est prêt pour les nuits
réunionnaises il faudrait qu'on les vive
ce qu'on arrive et que hier et on s'est
couché pas si tard que ça mais je
reprends votre terme visiblement la
vivre ensemble colle bien donc voilà on
a été accueilli qu'avec des sourires et
beaucoup beaucoup de de gentillesse à
tous les niveaux depuis qu'on a posé le
pied sur sur l'île un peu de un peu de
Rome aussi les hommes sont pressés les
hommes sans sincères
[Musique]
plus de 25 ans de carrière Louise
Attaque c'est 5 albums une compilation 4
victoires de la musique et des tubes
allez viens je t'emmène au vent je
t'emmène au-dessus des gens une carrière
mais surtout une force incroyable
[Musique]
un groupe on en a qu'un dans la vie
c'est empêche pas les aventures autres
ici et là c'est notre colonne vertébrale
donc rejouez ensemble régulièrement à
chaque fois en un maintenant de
nouvelles chansons c'est un bonheur donc
c'est on recommence à quasiment à zéro à
chaque fois avec évidemment le temps qui
passe notre musique qui évolue mais
c'est ce plaisir là donc il faut être
régulièrement à se retourner vers les
copains pour repartir ensemble après ce
qui s'ajoute à ça c'est les gens et là
on est gâté effectivement depuis 30 ans
on est gâté avec ça on a toujours un
public devant nous qui a toujours un
petit peu envie de faire la fête
faire la fête et combattre l'inertie du
succès après une longue pause Louise
Attaque repart à la source des studios
ensuite des grandes salles et des grands
festivals non sans anxiété un peu de
frousse oui mais il y a beaucoup
d'adrénaline et surtout beaucoup
d'impatience moi je suis persuadé qu'on
a ça en commun tous les trois on a la
frousse mais on a très hâte que ça
commence et de retrouver les gens donc
c'est l'impatience qui gagne à chaque
fois je trouve
du moins mon petit retard à 22h ce soir
ses camarades de longue date innombrons
le public de leur tube avec des
surprises difficiles de ne pas accepter
l'invitation
[Musique]